In the video on the Fourth
Coalition, I forgot to add to
one super important
consequence of
the Treaties of Tilsit.
And especially the Treaty
of Tilsit with Prussia.
I already talked about that it
was all about carving up
Prussia, and humiliating
Prussia.
And really removing it from
the status of one the
preeminent powers.
And all I talked about was the
loss of the territories of
Prussia west of the Elbe.
And that's about that
area right there.
But just as important
as that, the
Polish holdings of Prussia.
So all of this area right over
here, this also was removed
from Prussia and became a
French satellite state.
It became the Duchy of Warsaw.
So I just really want
to emphasize.
The Treaty of Tilsit, I only
emphasized kind of what
happened on the western side
of Prussia, but the eastern
side of Prussia also
got carved up.
And Prussia essentially
lost half of its size.
So it's very dramatic
humiliation for Prussia at the
end of the Treaty of Tilsit.
Or the Treaties of Tilsit.
Now with that out of the way,
we talked about in the last
video, that at the end of the
Fourth Coalition, Napoleon was
kind of near the peak
of his power.
He'd kind of done everything
right.
He had this kind of steady
upward momentum, or France had
a steady upward momentum
in its power.
But what we're going to see in
this video, at least the
beginnings of the downfall
of Napoleon.
And it's not going to
be obvious when
you look at the territory.
Because from a territorial point
of view, you're going to
see in this video that he's
actually gaining territory.
But he is going to start doing
some of the actions that end
up undermining him.
So we talked about in the last
video, we talked about this
whole notion of the Continental
System, where
Napoleon was obsessed with
people on the continent of
Europe boycotting England,
not trading with England.
And he figured this is the only
way that he could really
undermine England's dominance
on the ocean.
Or eventually maybe even
undermine England generally.
So as we said, in the Treaties
of Tilsit he got Russia to
participate in the Continental
System.
So he wanted everyone
to buy into it.
And one party that, at this
point, we're talking about--
we're in 1807 now-- one party
that wasn't all that keen in
participating in the
Continental System was Portugal.
That's Portugal right there.
So Napoleon goes and chats--
well they didn't chat
directly-- but he gets
the agreement
of the King of Spain.
This is Charles IV, and he's
going to look like a bit of a
fool and this video.
And Napoleon says, hey Charles,
let's go in there,
let's go into Portugal, that
little upstart country that
doesn't want to participate
in the Continental System.
You and me, we'll
invade together.
We'll bring them into kind of
our realm of influence.
And we can both kind of pillage
the lands and get the
wealth of Portugal.
Charles IV, he's all
up for this.
So a combined French and Spanish
force invade Portugal.
So in 1807, this is
the end of 1807,
it's actually in October.
In October, you have a combined
French and Spanish
invasion of Portugal.
And they are able to take
Portugal, but we're going to
see that it's reasonably
temporary.
Now I just mentioned that this
guy is going to look like the
fool of this video.
And the reason is, because
with the excuse of
reinforcements, obviously to get
to Portugal, you have to
go through Spain.
So with the excuse of sending in
reinforcements, Napoleon in
1808-- and now we're talking
about early 1808, in
particular in March.
So with the excuse of sending
in reinforcements to support
the Portugal campaign, and Spain
is like your my ally,
sure, send those hundreds of
thousands of troops right
through our territory.
We're not going to
worry about it.
And with that excuse, Napoleon
was able to send 100,000
troops and occupy Madrid.
So this is one of
those lessons of
never get too greedy.
This guy got greedy, wanted
to help Napoleon.
Or I guess the other lesson
is be careful who
your friends are.
This guy wanted to invade
Portugal, but the side effect
of it is that Madrid
gets occupied.
And that actually he
gets dethrowned.
And so you have this situation
here, the French are now in
control of Spain.
In May of 1808-- and this is
really going to be the first
little spark that is kind of
the downfall of Napoleon.
In May 2, 1808, a popular
uprising starts in Madrid.
Dos de Mayo.
So a popular uprising
in Madrid.
And at the same time, a little
bit after that--
So you can imagine, this is
a hugely tumultuous time.
You have this occupation of
Portugal with the excuse of
reinforcements in March.
The French troops
occupy Madrid.
Then in May-- so a couple of
months later-- a popular
uprising starts in Madrid.
This leads to popular uprisings
throughout Spain.
But at the very same time as
this-- this is a little bit
after the uprising in May--
Napoleon says, oh, this is
just a little uprising, I'm
still in control of Spain.
He appoints his other brother--
remember, there's
this whole business he's putting
his brothers in charge
of different parts
of the Empire.
He puts his brother Joseph, he
appoints his brother Joseph--
or you could kind of say-- he
inserts his brother Joseph as
the King of Spain.
So this is all in kind
of early, mid-1808.
Spain is in all of
this turmoil.
A new king has been appointed,
who is Napoleon's brother.
The old king is no
longer in charge.
You have this ongoing
battle in Portugal.
They don't have a firm hold
on Portugal just yet.
And in the rest of 1808, the
uprising that occurs
throughout Spain is actually
pretty successful in enforcing
the French troops to retreat.
And a major, I guess, aspect of
this uprising is it's one
of the first real national
uprisings in history.
It's people saying we are
Spanish, we do not like being
controlled by the French.
We do not like how they have
treated our royalty.
We as a nation are
going to rise up.
And the other interesting aspect
of this whole uprising
that starts in Madrid with Dos
de Mayo, but then it starts
continuing throughout the whole
nation, is the idea of
guerrilla warfare.
Not gorilla warfare.
And this comes from the Spanish
for little war.
Not from the large ape.
And what it implies, you
probably heard the word on the
news before, is kind of a
non-conventional style of
fighting, where small little
groups kind of engage their
enemy in very nontraditional
styles.
So it becomes a very painful--
at least for it Napoleon's
forces-- it became very
difficult fighting these
non-conventional battles
all over Spain.
So they were able to force
the French to retreat.
Napoleon says, gee,
you know what?
If you want a job well done,
you've got to do it yourself.
So Napoleon comes in at the end
of the year, and then he
retakes Madrid.
So December of 1808, Napoleon
back in Madrid.
Now, you might say all
is fine and well.
Now Napoleon is back here.
He has firm control of Spain.
But not everything is good.
Because as you could imagine,
there's all these other
characters here that keep
forming coalitions for and
against Napoleon.
Even when they say that they're
allied, you know that
in the back of their minds they
can't wait until they can
declare the next war
on Napoleon.
So in 1809-- let me write this
down-- Austria declares war.
And since Great Britain was in--
at this point in time--
perpetual war with France, this
becomes the Fifth Coalition.
But this one is fairly
short-lived.
Napoleon says gee, I got these
guys on my eastern front.
Austria is re-declaring
war on me.
So he leaves Spain to
go lead that fight.
And he leaves 300,000 of
his best troops in
Spain to hold Spain.
And frankly, this is the most
important side effect of the
Fifth Coalition, is that it
makes Napoleon go to fight
Austria, to lead that effort,
as opposed to
worrying about Spain.
And essentially by doing that--
and I don't know if
it's necessarily the fact that
Napoleon wasn't there.
But it could be because Napoleon
wasn't there-- is
that Spain just becomes
a major thorn
in Napoleon's side.
This guerrilla warfare just
continues on and on and on.
And it just goes
back and forth.
And the French will
win a battle and
they'll win another battle.
But they still don't
have control.
And these guerrillas will kind
of peck at them and continue
the uprising.
And this really just drains
the French army.
And really just gets at them
little bit by little bit,
really over the remainder
of Napoleon's reign.
So all the way until 1814.
We haven't gone over that yet.
But this occurs all
the way to 1814.
So I said at the beginning the
video, this is one of the
starting points of Napoleon's
downfall.
That's just because he was just
stuck in Spain from 1808
on, just continuing to have to
send troops and supplies and
reinforcements and wealth to
support what they called the
Peninsular Campaign.
And it just drains him.
It drains his resources,
it drains his energy.
And it really hurts his ability
to fight wars with all
of the other people who he
needs to fight wars with.
This is one of the
major downfalls.
The other one, which we'll
probably talk about in the
next video or video
after that, is
his invasion of Russia.
Which he does in 1812.
One could debate which
one drains
France's resources more.
But the invasion of
Russia really
decimates Napoleon's forces.
And really makes him susceptible
to really conquest
by England and all of
the other allies.
And we're going to see that
in a couple of videos.
So you have this been Peninsular
Campaign continuing
to drain Napoleon.
It all started because he
wanted to enforce the
Continental System
on Portugal.
And he got a little
bit greedy.
And he also wanted
to conquer Spain.
And just to highlight
why it's called
the Peninsular Campaign.
This right here, a little bit
of geography, this is called
the Iberian Peninsula right
there that I'm circling.
So you could call it the Iberian
Peninsular Campaign,
because it's everything that's
going on in this Peninsula in
Spain and Portugal.
Now if we back up a little bit
back to 1808, where we had
this uprising in Spain, and
they were able to push the
French back.
At the same time, you also had a
popular uprising in Portugal
roughly in the fall, late
summer or fall of 1808.
The British got excited.
They saw it as their chance to
push Napoleon out of Portugal.
So you have this
gentleman right
here, Sir Arthur Wellesley.
He's a future Duke
of Wellington.
And he's eventually going to
be responsible for pushing
Napoleon out of Spain
entirely.
Or at least out of Madrid.
Him and along with the British
and along with the Portuguese
are able to push the French
out in August of 1808.
So let me put this in my not so
neatly drawn timeline here.
So in December, Napoleon is
back, so right before that in
August, out of Portugal.
And this is another motivation
for Napoleon to say,
gee, you know what?
Things aren't going well on the
Iberian Peninsula, I have
to take charge of
things myself.
Now, at the very same time as
all of this is happening, and
this is really just kind of
out of interest. Well it's
more than out of interest,
because actually it has huge
global repercussions.
You might say, OK, well you have
this Iberian Peninsula.
Spain is going back and
forth between the
French and the guerillas.
And Portugal has this whole
situation where their king was
dethrowned, but then the British
help and take it back.
But you could imagine, these
nations are in just a super
state of flux.
Now you could also imagine, the
King of Spain wasn't just
the King of Spain, he was King
of the Spanish Empire.
And the Spanish Empire, the main
land mass of the Spanish
Empire was in the Americas.
So this right here.
That was the Spanish
Empire at the time.
This was a 400 year old
Spanish Empire.
Starting with Columbus sailing
the ocean blue in 1492.
You had this huge
Spanish Empire.
And one of the really important
side effects of
Napoleon invading Spain and
having this long protracted
engagement in Spain, is it
catalyzed the ability of these
colonies at the time to start
looking for their
independence.
And we're going to do whole
videos on that in the future.
But this really is one of the
things that allowed them to
get independence.
Obviously, if the empire is in
flux, these guys can say hey,
gee, why do we have to listen
to that nation anymore?
We don't even know who's
in charge there.
At the same time, same
thing in Portugal.
Brazilian independence didn't
come until a little bit later
after this period, but
Napoleon's invasion is what
really sparked the beginning
of a lot
of turmoil in Portugal.
And that eventually is one of
the causes that leads to the
eventual independence
of Brazil.
That doesn't happen for another
10 or 15 years.
But you could imagine, this is
where a lot of that action can
be traced back.
Now, another interesting
point that
occurred around this time.
And actually, I didn't tell
you what happened
on the Fifth Coalition.
I said Austria declared war.
Obviously Britain was
already at war.
So it was the Fifth Coalition.
Napoleon had to leave, that
maybe made Spain a little bit
harder to hold for France.
And that's why it kind of
bled France slowly.
But Napoleon was able to
take care of Austria.
And then he was able to
take a little bit
more land from them.
Actually Galicia, this area of
Austria was given to the Duchy
of Warsaw, which was a French
satellite state.
And then Austria once again, had
to say oh Napoleon, we're
your friend, we're going to
do whatever you ask us to.
So you can imagine at this time
landwise, the empire of
Napoleon seemed pretty
dramatic.
You could include Spain here.
Although he had to spend a lot
of resources to keep Spain.
And then now we had Austria, at
least it was in the fold.
You know Prussia was not
really happy about it.
But this whole area here, the
western half of Poland was
under French control.
Germany-- the Confederacy
of the Rhine--
which is now Germany.
And then a good bit of Italy,
the Kingdom of Italy was also
a French satellite state.
But Napoleon, of course, he
wanted everyone to participate
in the Continental System.
That's the only way to really
strangle England.
And the Papal States were
not participating in the
Continental System.
So he sent some people over
to kind of try to
convince them to.
And when they didn't, they
occupied the Papal States.
So French troops occupied
the Papal States.
And then once again, this
was still back in 1808.
This is actually early
1808, it's just
on a different front.
So in February, up
here, in 1808.
Actually, that's before they
even occupied Madrid.
So in 1808, February, French
troops occupy Papal States.
They essentially give them over
to the Kingdom of Italy,
which at that time was a
French satellite state.
So it's almost like annexing
it to France.
And then once the Fifth
Coalition was done with,
Napoleon felt so good about
himself, that he formally
annexed the Papal States.
Now we're in 1809.
In 1809, he formally-- The
Papal States are actually
annexed into the
French Empire.
Now you can imagine that
the Pope wasn't
that happy about this.
This is the Pope at the time,
this is Pius VII.
He wasn't so happy about it.
So he excommunicates Napoleon.
And I'll do a whole video
on excommunication.
But it's really about as bad as
something you could do to
someone within the powers
of the Catholic Church.
And by implication, you're no
longer part of the church, and
you'll probably go to hell now,
at least if the Pope has
anything to do with it.
So Napoleon wasn't
happy about this.
He sent some people, some
officers, once again to talk
to the Pope about it.
To say hey, gee, why
do you want to
excommunicate Napoleon?
Why don't you just play nice?
Why don't you just agree to
whatever Napoleon says?
The Pope doesn't agree, and
so he gets abducted.
This is why it's interesting.
Napoleon, he's not afraid to
take some serious action.
So he gets abducted in 1809
by French officers.
And it's not clear, it's not
obvious that Napoleon told
them to do it.
But once he was abducted, and
they actually started
shuttling him all around France
depending on who needed
to talk to him.
Or if they were afraid that the
British might try to free
him from one port, they would
send them some place else.
But it wasn't clear that
Napoleon ordered this.
But he never ordered
his release.
So in some ways, you got
to say that it was
sanctioned by Napoleon.
So all of this mess starts, you
know, Napoleon is messing
with the Pope.
He has this ongoing bleeding
going on in Spain.
And that ends actually in 1812
where Sir Arthur Wellesley
finally retakes Madrid.
But during this whole period,
you can imagine it's really
draining into the resources
of the French Empire.